the investigators with the surveillance  video from the school I do want to  update one thing we just received word  that the one of the 14 year old victim  that Vasco has also passed away just  just moments ago  so our fatalities now we're two civil  with heavy heart we're gonna move  forward with the investigation to figure  out what went wrong and I hate to have  saugus be added to the names of  Columbine parkland Sandy Hook but it's a  reality that affects us all throughout  the nation something we have to deal  with and as captain Louis said we got to  figure out what are we doing wrong and  how can we stop this from happening in  the future so we'll figure that overtime  you can